what did people use before
that's what we're finding out today i
recently found out that before
people use toilet paper americans used
to
wipe their ass with corn what's wrong
with you americans
this is what our bathroom used to look
like look at this
a jolly good time that is things were
better before
okay i'm a boomer i don't care i'm so
jealous
i never got to experience this so people
would wipe their asses with these
but the best part about it is that they
shared it
no way they found information from
seneca's ladders they are mentioned
through roman literature i read this
uh relates to suicide of jeremy glady
who shoved a stick tip with a sponge
devoted to
the vilest uses down his throat rather
than head
into the arena to die by wild animal
i'm sorry what i remember reading about
his friend committing suicide but he
drank like
a poison not sticking he shoved a stick
tip with a sponge
down his tree
oh god they've also used ceramics to
wipe their ass i don't know why anyone
would ever think of that but
someone did and people did it huh in
china they used hygiene sticks
but there were nothing hygiene about
them since they'd spread parasites
between each other's anuses
number two that's right i'm on countdown
channel
so back in the day before the alarm
clock was invented
you may have heard about this they were
called knocker uppers
which basically had this long stick
and tap people's windows to wake them up
great idea but who wake up
knocker-upper i guess it's not too
different from a wake-up call in a hotel
right
i always thought that was so weird
asking him wake-up call at a hotel like
bro just set the alarm on your phone why
would anyone do that
all right what's better a guy with a
stick tapping your window
or what's that god awful apple alarm
sound
i'll take the knocker things were better
before point proven again
past two modern society zero
this one is weird number three before
pregnancy tests were
invented but the ancient egyptians had a
fun way
of determining pregnancy a fun way a fun
little time
uh the lady in question peed on a pile
of wheat and barley seeds
and if over the course of several days
that we'd sprouted she expects a girl
and if it was barley a boy interestingly
enough
research had tested his method and found
that it was 70 percent
accurate what what
it may have been estrogen in the urine
that helped the grain to sprout
how the [ __ ] did people figure that out
get out of here
i'm sorry what then came the rabbit test
it was called the friedman test which
involved injecting
pee into a female rabbit huh
then came the frog test stop inject
urine
in a frog and see if the female frog
starts to up
women stop it women stop it
oh god okay modern society society you
get one
two one okay this one is [ __ ] great
all right you got a headache
what do you do okay yeah i had to wait
it out bring some water
maybe take an aspirin or whatever it's
called lame that's
lame as hell you know what the romans
did they took a black torpedo fish
or an electric ray to immediately remove
and permanently cure a headache however
long lasting and intolerable
they put the fish on where there was
pain
and removes headaches you electrify your
head with a fish
that's so much better can i see an
electric ray fish i gotta see it the
strongest shot can knock a human
unconscious hell yeah these rays are
usually found near muddy or sandy sea
floors i want this
i want to try this look at this
sting me imagine just taking two two of
them and
had it cured so much better past once
again
3-1 god damn it instantly
there were of course other methods to
cure uh
illnesses back in the day what do you do
before modern medicine
apparently what they thought and i think
i've heard about this before is that
they saw as a lot of illnesses of just
being the result of having too much
blood
so they invented bloodletting basically
mentions you just
let the blood suck out you suck at the
blood good times
hell yeah hey see this stream big
he's like it look how intimidating he is
damn
that's the healthy flow you got there uh
apparently the
this did uh more harm than any good
love that weakening the patient further
now he's good he's
he looks good and why the hell did they
do that i don't understand how they can
figure out that frogs are uh peeing on
barley or
the beans and [ __ ] will determine the
sex of a baby but they can't figure out
this is doing more harm than good
god damn it there are so many images and
weird stuff from this like
like bro leave the man alone he doesn't
want to do it clearly
stop that i bet it was just like a
fetish people did
i'm like yeah this is real trust me oh
they would use
leeches oh bloody bollocks in it i ain't
gonna do that
sweden what's wrong with you sweden oh
it's varmland
okay that explains it okay fine modern
medicine wins
congratulations i actually i would
rather just die
you know what no one gets a point i'd
rather die thank you
radiation was perceived exclusively as a
positive phenomenon
which swindlers didn't fail to take
advantage of you could buy cosmetics
food and drinks enriched with radium and
thorium
radioactive souvenirs and even devices
for saturating water with radioactive
elements
sadly there were casualties athlete evan
byers
drank huge doses of the radium-based
medicine radethor
which led to his death the wall street
journal reacted to the sad incident with
a headline reading
the radium water worked fine until his
jaw came off
[Laughter]
okay all right wall street journal fake
news
no the water is fine i mean
so what his jaw fell off what the
so clearly you know health wasn't the
best back in the day
boo hoo what are you gonna do okay they
used to have bathing machines
unlike us people in the 18th and 19th
centuries just couldn't go into the
water on the beach
why not they had to use bathing machines
special carts that look like beach huts
why
this isn't england this could be
brighton honestly
oh no way off canelo it's brighton in it
why why brighton what's the point the
carts were driven into the water
so that bathers could swim without any
prying eyes watching them
furthermore women's bathing machines
were set some distance away from men's
so it's bloody bathing bad for the girls
get out get out of here i want you back
water near me mate brought a bullet city
oh man uh yeah it's uh
based on this image alone i would say a
better before
yeah the past wins again 3-1 baby
let's go all right this one is a bit
weird
but condoms before plastic was invented
what did people do what do you use
animal intestines that's right
they use the bladder or the intestine
here's one
nice shape i'm just gonna go and flat
out say uh
the modern modern society wins even
though terrible
it's it's better it's gotta be bad and
you know i haven't tried it
okay my modern win fine three two okay
fine
god damn it i ain't sticking anything in
there what the [ __ ]
oh no bruh
who had a snob going out like a [ __ ]
yo they had images on the mate oh let's
go
dude victorian peepees all right not bad
sweden sweden has the oldest condom
sweden
let's go sweden space swedish
ice is so small oh
[ __ ] now one of the most important ones
sports drinks or energy drinks if you
will
or gamer drinks g-fuel oh that's perfect
segment for sponsor
we have a new g-fuel hydration has no
caffeine baby
very excited for this is the reason why
i wanted the use of flavor because it
goes so well with a no caffeine version
love this try it out i know a lot of you
guys have been asking for no caffeine
zero sugar zero calories zero caffeine
baby takes just as
less food now i can drink g fuel
24 7 at last
but what did they use before energy
drinks or sports drinks or gpu
alcohol they drink they drink they drink
alcohol
today alcohol is known to cause
dehydration you're telling me they
didn't figure that out
you can't tell if you're dehydrated each
runner had people on bikes or cars
waiting for them
along the path with alcohol hell yeah
better before
guaranteeing they refilled themselves
with shots of whiskey brandy and
alcoholic drinks
if athletes drank anything other than
hard drink they were not considered
macho
oh hell yeah that is so
incredibly dumb but i will say
better passed past us 4-1
hell yeah okay last one
which was uh before in the roman times
in order to clean their clothes so get
tough stains out they would use p
because p contains ammonia which
i mean that that's the same stuff in uh
modern cleaning products right
i'm not sure if they still use it and it
was so popular
that they had to put a tax on it how do
you put a tax on pee
i don't know yeah ingredient found in
house household cleaners today
in post attacks on distribution of urine
oh that's worse then
[ __ ] taxes on everything you're gonna
tax my pee now
huh you can't make me not pee uh the
weirdest part about it was that
they didn't just use it for their uh
for their clothing they used it to
whiten their teeth
all right this one gets the this one
modern wins
because i ain't paying taxes on my p 4 2
baby
close call but the pass wins this has
been
what did we do before i don't know this
has been learning with pewdiepie i don't
know what the [ __ ] i was interested and
i looked it up and i made a video out of
it what do you want from me hopefully it
was entertaining brofist see you
tomorrow